it just goes to show you you don't need
nuclear weapons and
fleets of bombers or even guns to spark
a crisis
in a european state all you need is a is
a bunch of
tired border guards who leave the gates
open
by accident really morocco claims that
that
is what happened
[Music]
this was by all appearances a cold
calculated move by morocco so a little
background
see morocco claims a huge tract of land
in western sahara inhabited by the
sarawi people
all they want is independence many of
these people
you know much like morocco but with it
having bombed sarawi refugee camps and
forced hundreds and thousands of people
into exile how is any of these spain's
faults you may ask well
madrid led the leader of polissario the
sarawi resistance movement
into spain to be treated for covert
why doesn't spain consider it should
have to inform morocco of the presence
of garlic
would they rather consort with the
enemies of morocco
this is the test of our relationship the
border gates were flung open and
migrants
flooded into suitor a spanish enclave in
africa
many many were children we saw
horrible pictures of spanish police and
military cornering and
beating miners amongst others not a
pretty sight for residents who
themselves
fear the worst as the days go by
crime is going to increase because they
are going to need to eat
so what are they going to do robbery
i think that we should get on well with
morocco because it has been seen and
proven
when there is something in morocco that
they don't like the open borders
neither spain nor europe were all too
happy with morocco's apparent stunt
it is essentially blackmail no one can
blackmail the european union
suta is europe that border is a european
border and what happens there what has
been happening there is not a problem
for madrid
it is a problem for everyone as morocco
wanted
spain has now launched an investigation
against the leader
of polisario and everyone in spain knows
that if he is found
not guilty moroccan border guards will
again
experience a bout of collective fatigue
an inexplicable malady that also
afflicts turkish border guards
amongst others due to this situation an
overcrowding and reception centers
i was forced to make yesterday afternoon
written representations to the european
commission
notifying them that cyprus is entering
in a state of emergency as far as
migration is concerned
and that there is no further capacity to
host additional migrants
thousands of syrian migrants from turkey
and syria
have been storming the beaches and
crossings in cyprus too
migrants have become a tool europe's
achilles heel it is inconceivable that
migrants and refugees can be used as
geopolitical pawns to put pressure on
the european union as a whole
and i think we need to be very very
strict when this happens
make no mistake europe isn't
the victim here those migrants are
coming from syria
where europe helped train and arm
legions
of jihadists from iraq which was turned
upside down by u.s invasion supported
by european states from libya which
primarily european jets and
bombs transformed from one of africa's
richest countries
into the world's largest slave market if
there is a victim here
it is the eight-year-old migrants whose
homelands
have been savaged by foreign
intervention and who morocco
is exploiting to crush an independence
movement
it doesn't like the former mep noticed
marius does believe that everybody
involved in the crisis should take their
share
of responsibilities turkey morocco
and other countries should abide to
international law and they should
protect their own frontiers
and they should not allow migrants to
enter illegally into other countries
the european commission should press
the member states of the european union
to accept
the principle of reallocation
the member states of the european union
should
show their solidarity for frontier
countries that is to say spain
italy and greece